hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to
askmev3 so this is the third installment
of a fun little video series where i
basically answer a bunch of questions
from twitter uh and some other social
media for a video and uh i also have
some questions from the last episode
from the comments section of the v2 so
if you want to ask questions for the
next ask mkbhd video feel free to leave
them in the comment section below this
video or i might just like answer them
in a comment anyway but either way let's
go ahead and get started i have a bunch
of questions let's go do you edit the
videos that you make for your channel
yourself or you've got people to do the
job so everything that you see on this
channel is completely
crafted by me 100 there is no like
second guy or other behind the scenes
crew working on anything it's just me
and i feel like it's sort of like a
portfolio that way of the videos i make
and the projects that i work on what was
the very first device you reviewed the
first one ever was the motorola droid
the original og droid and i was really
proud of that video in fact no shame i'm
i'm just going to leave a link to that
og droid review
right below that like button if you want
to check it out i think it was kind of
good i think i shot that with my canon
t2i and like the built-in microphone in
my laptop
but i was really proud of it and i
worked just as hard on that video as i
do on my current reviews so if you want
to check it out there it is do you think
you'll do more news type videos
considering the success of your iphone
video ah good question uh mostly because
i i don't know i i guess i expect the
iphone stuff because so many people are
interested in iphones i kind of expect
that to do really well but i don't know
if that was a news type of video i still
think that's a in my my current
style of i didn't explain video on it
and i did sort of an impressions video
on the materials so i guess yeah i'm
still covering iphone stuff and what's
funny is my three most viewed videos now
in the past month according to youtube
analytics are my three iphone videos
that i've done this year but either way
yeah i plan on doing the same variety of
content that i've planned on what's your
nba team you cheer for and what do you
think about lebron heading to cleveland
so the team i chew for is the los
angeles clippers uh and i'm a fan of a
bunch of players on that team especially
chris paul jamal crawford deandre jordan
but uh about lebron heading home i don't
really mind that much i mean props to
him for going home that seems great
especially for ohio but i don't really
mind that much i'm still going to be
watching clippers games can you say boss
boss do you own a dog because you should
i don't own a dog mostly because if i
were to like leave and go like on a trip
for ultimate or school or something i
would not have any place to keep that
dog because you know you kind of have to
feed it and walk it and stuff that's
pretty important but i think in a later
time i will probably end up getting a
dog or a cat or something that i can pet
what's your favorite piece of video gear
except for your camera i think i'm gonna
cheat a little bit just because video
gear is only a couple of things and i'm
gonna say the lens the lens i'm shooting
this video on now and the lens that i
shoot a lot of videos on is the sigma 18
to 35 i'll leave a link to it below it
is easily my favorite lens ever and i've
used a lot of lenses in my time i've
used some very expensive lenses from
canon uh from sigma and from some others
but this sigma 18 to 35 is a beast and
it's the fastest zoom lens ever and i
love the wide angle stuff it's it's
awesome i don't know if i can say enough
about it i've never reviewed it but if
you watch other reviews everyone else
likes it too it's great can we have a
rundown of all the cameras you've used
in the past alright so the video i'm
shooting this on now and what i've shot
for for the last couple of months is the
red scarlet
may or may not do a video on the red but
i feel like it's a possibility uh before
this i was using the canon c100 for a
couple of months before that i was using
the canon 5d mark iii before that it was
the canon 60d you can see i've used a
lot of canon and before that it was the
canon t2i and then before that my first
camera that i ever bought was the sanyo
zakdi cg10 still an old favorite what is
your least favorite part of doing
youtube videos tim that's a great
question because most people ask what's
like my favorite or the best part of
making youtube videos uh i would say the
least favorite part
um
is probably just
being like unsatisfied or being your own
biggest critic although it is a pretty
important part of making your own
creative content being like unsatisfied
or unable to achieve like a video
look or style that you wish you could
make is is really frustrating
but i guess it's still a motivation a
motivator on the other hand of things so
i guess there's not too much bad about
making youtube videos what was your
first job my first job i was a caddie uh
a caddy at a local country club i've
been a golfer for more than 10 years now
and being a caddy was like a natural
first job for me to get and spoiler it's
a really good job if you're into golf or
if you're into or want to be into golf
that's an awesome first job to have do
you ever do videos pantsless just
because you can no but now that you
mention it
you're right i could what's one tech
device you want to own but can't other
than a tesla tech device that i can't
own probably
the perfect uh like the perfect piece of
gear like the perfect microphone or the
perfect camera because it just doesn't
exist maybe that's cheating because
these things don't actually happen in
real life but i would love to have a
perfect microphone that could perfectly
isolate just the amount of sound that i
want to record and block out everything
else
but of course physics don't really allow
for these types of things can you do a
behind-the-scenes video showing how you
make videos yeah so this is something
i've considered doing for a little bit
mostly haven't done it yet because it's
really hard to like do a behind the
scenes of how i'm making an actual video
when i don't have someone to shoot me
making a video so it would be like me
making a fake video while i make a real
video about how i make the fake video
kind of difficult i don't know leave a
thumbs up if you like want to see
something like that like how
the videos
become
what they are sort of tutorial i guess
but it's something i've considered and i
think it might be an interesting topic
at least to cover do you use art or
dalvik on your nexus so every phone i've
taken out of a box for the past couple
of months i always almost immediately
switch it to the art android runtime but
now that the nexus i have is running
android l developer preview there is no
dalvik art is the default so i guess i
will no longer have to switch nexuses
over to art as soon as i take them out
the box android runtime is where it's at
what is the one thing no phone does that
you wish they could last a week on
battery without charging at least and
you know phones used to be able to do
that how was your experience with the g
watch and android wear been i've had a
pretty mixed experience with the g watch
which is the one that i've been using
i'm still waiting for the moto 360
because i am most interested in that as
a smart watch but my time with the
g-watch has been interesting number one
it doesn't last very long on battery it
lasts a day and a half
maximum usually a bit less than a day
and the other thing is the step counter
i don't know if it's using my wrist as
the step counter instead of my phone
sensor because i was eating breakfast
with unbox therapy in san francisco
after google i o and i took 900 steps
while eating breakfast so that's clearly
not accurate so i haven't just i've just
stopped using the step counter
altogether i turned it off
but other than that i like having the
notifications on my wrist i was using a
pebble for the months before google i o
so i was really interested in how it
shows notifications so i like the g
watch as a concept as a proof of concept
but i'm way more pumped for the moto
360. pancakes or waffles definitely
pancakes
no question about that fellow tall
person here worst thing about being tall
other people's showers
other people's showers
think about it is the rx100 mark iii
significantly better than the previous
versions or should i save my money and
buy a previous version so i've owned
this little rx100 mark iii uh what i
think is the best pocket camera ever for
a couple of weeks now i reviewed the
rx100 mark ii i would say if you really
want that optical viewfinder if if
that's something you actually value in a
point and shoot which not a lot of
people do but it's an awesome feature
then you have to get the mark iii and if
you really want a slightly wider lens
like you would get on this it's a 24 to
70 then you have to get the mark iii
other than that you can get the rx 100
mark one and it's still an incredibly
good camera a very similar sensor very
similar images there's just a bunch of
slight improvements
on the second version and the third
version but i love the third version and
i would recommend it to anyone who can't
get it so there you go guys that's just
a couple of the questions i got on
twitter over the past couple of weeks
and from the last ask me video again if
you want to ask questions feel free to
ask them in the comments section below
or follow me on twitter shoot me a
question over there i'll answer it just
fun quick little stuff i figured i'd do
this video to get that across either way
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace
you